you know that that was a very compelling
aspect of his press conference last
night and other moments included
questions about whether or not he's done
enough to earn a second contract with
the team and he said i don't care about
the contract i care about winning well
if winning is the priority for cam
newton he's already answered his own
question if you want to win you don't
stay in new england next year do you
is that where you go well if you you've
seen you've seen the quality of the
offensive talent around you if you want
to win that's not where you play well
okay but you know we we know that you
can change a team around in a hurry and
there's some aspects there that he
probably does like you know the fact
that they have an offensive line that
you know every week just plows people
out of the way in the run game and do
that you know they're special so
i i think and the other thing mike i
think we gotta ask you know who else is
gonna bring him in to be a starting
quarterback right that's the other thing
so i don't know if that's really out
there at this point
i don't know what the feel is i have no
feel from anybody i know new england i
don't think is in that type of
conversation right now i know that they
really respect cam newton and his work
ethic and his energy and charisma and
leadership that he brings into the
building every day you know but the
offense has flaws as we know you know
one hey the offense would be better with
tom brady if he was there right now
definitely brady knows every inkling of
the offense so they could throw that out
there and yeah brady would find ways to
yeah we'll get it wouldn't be pretty but
they'd move the ball better than they
did
you know or have this year
so cam newton doesn't know the whole
offense like that
cam noon's a different type of
quarterback all together i have to think
new england as smart as they are are
realistic to know like damn we haven't
really given the guy a chance to really
be successful so i would think from that
aspect they haven't closed the door on
bringing cam newton back next year i
wouldn't you know the other thing you
got to talk about is just okay so then
who are you going to bring in who's
going to be that guy are you sure he's
going to be better so with that
offensive line you know damien harris
are running back i think they need to
get another big time running back mike
they need to get a home run hitter they
need a raheem mozart a breeder somebody
like that you know we watched that sony
michelle big run last night that should
have been a touchdown the top running
backs in football their head hits the
hits the goal post it's a touchdown but
it's just underwhelming that way but
they get him a few receivers and they
have to run an offense that fits cam
newton he's not going to be brady it has
to be you know run play action the
threat of him running the speed sweeps
some of that stuff we saw him do in
carolina and i think they can formulate
that around him they just don't have the
players to do it right now and i don't
know where it goes it hasn't been good
enough uh i know that and i feel bad for
cam newton in a lot of ways i really do
because it's tough but
um i don't think it's dead here's a
challenge you're the patriots yeah
here's the challenge yeah well i got two
points to make yeah first of all
bill belichick is so accustomed to
getting people under his thumb and
pressing yeah when it comes to contracts
when you know tom brady lived in fear
for 20 years that bill belichick was
going to wake up one day and say
tom brady's salary cap number tom
brady's current talent see you later tom
brady we're going to move on to somebody
else that's one of the reasons why brady
always took less people like he's a
great teammate he's being selfless no he
was afraid that he was going to get run
out of town at some point because bill
belichick decided he was making too much
money that's why he took less folks and
they were able to get cam newton for
peanuts last year and that they played
part of his
audio from earlier this year where they
were talking about they they went all in
to win super bowls and they're paying
the price that's baloney that's bullcrap
that's a poor excuse from bill belichick
and the bottom line is with cam newton
they laid in the weeds for as long as
they could they made the move at the
absolute perfect time they offered him a
contract when there was no one else
interested and they got him
for nothing and they're going to try to
play that game again i would think i
could see belichick trying to play that
game again let him become a free agent
let him realize there's no one out there
that's gonna throw a bunch of money at
him and then wait and wait and wait and
wait and wait and wait and then move and
i would suggest that if you truly want
to have the kind of connection you need
with cam newton and to get the most out
of him next year you need to move
quickly and reward him for the effort
and the sacrifice and the dedication and
and everything he's done to try to learn
the patriot way
with his one hand behind his back
basically because of no off-season
program and joining the team so late and
the pandemic and all of that and this
would be one of those moments that calls
for emotional intelligence where you
don't just wait and do the best possible
deal you can because it's in the best
interest of the team it's in the best
interest of the team to take care of
this guy and send a message to the rest
of the locker room that we are behind
him you should be behind him we like his
work ethic this is what gets you
rewarded here and that would be i think
the better approach yeah and this is a
delicate one because because chris
here's my question for you you worked up
there you know folks who you know you
hear all the time the the regular season
the preseason and
the playoffs of the regular season and
the super bowl is the postseason in the
minds of patriots fans how much of this
will they tolerate how many years of
this will they tolerate because they
could be looking
at two three four five years of this i
would think that up there in new england
you know after maybe if it gets next
year it looks like this
they're gonna get antsy up there i don't
know if that puts like you know bill or
anybody in the hot seat quite yet but i
think a next year of like one more year
of mediocrity mediocrity like we saw
this year yeah i think you're going to
start to hear new england fans you know
murmur and start getting a little you
know antsy that way i mean i'm a little
surprised by the way they've acted this
year anyways you know the way they treat
bill belichick on the local radio
stations i want to be like whoa i
wouldn't talk to anybody that way let
alone like the greatest coach i've ever
seen i'm shocked by it but like but this
is when the chickens come home to roost
you're right you act the way that he
you're right you can't if you step into
a pothole then you start getting some of
what you've been dishing out i was just
gonna say that you're exactly right
that's why i don't feel bad for bill
that way when they talk to him because
he's he's been disrespectful himself
that way too i think your thing about
cam is a really good thought mike and
you know i think that's i think that
might be on the horizon or on their
radar i think we have some evidence of
that to a degree i think that's why they
haven't gone to jared sidham and done
those things because i think of like
what you're saying i think there's still
a possibility in their brain where they
go we're going to bring cam newton back
we don't want to have to deal with
quarterback controversy stidhum cam
newton talk there's a good chance we
bring cam newton back i should say sorry
and i think that's what they're trying i
think that's what they're doing right
now is paying him the respect to you
know hey you're a guy you've done a lot
of good things we're not going to start
stitum and do all those things and start
that controversy because i think they
think there's still a chance but the big
thing too is he's got a his throwing
i've never seen him in a rut like this
i've seen him go through ruts before i
haven't seen it like this
to where we're moving up in the pocket
and there's a guy crossing the field and
he's wide open and we skip it on the
ground like there's definitely some
mechanical issues that cam newton's got
to go back to the drawing board he's got
to get look i mean think about cam
newton throwing the ball right now i'm
going to move a little but like it's
like he's a he's up there his shoulders
always scrunched up and then it leads to
that throw all the time and you and i
have talked and if you watch aaron
rodgers or josh allen they don't do
that and come over the top like that
it's more around
it's around it's coming around that way
brady rogers stafford whatever ma homes
they all do that right now cam newton
has this i'm so big and strong i'm gonna
jack my front shoulder up and i'm just
gonna overpower it and it's just too
much work and you can see he's got no
control of the football and the bad
thing is like my dad always says when
then you don't know you don't know where
the ball's gonna go it starts affecting
your decision-making because you go oh i
don't want to throw that because i don't
know if i can throw it the way i want to
throw it so let me see if i can find
somebody else and he's got to fix that
issue mike
this is another angle that the patriots
know the answer to but we don't now that
they've had a full year with them they
have a much better understanding of his
overall health picture remember it was
in the 2019 training camp and pre-season
phase where he was breaking in that new
throwing motion because of chronic
shoulder problems and then he had the
foot problem and he's had many issues
over the years and he's in the building
they've been around him they know what
he physically can and can't do
and if they decide frankly this guy's
wrong side of 30 he's a little too
banged up for us we've we've managed to
keep him healthy relatively speaking
this year but but the scars of past
injuries are keeping him from being the
guy that he was in 2015. they're not
going to broadcast that because look end
of the day he becomes a free agent
signed somewhere else they want to get
that extra little boost for the
compensatory draft pick formula so yeah
uh
you know their actions are going to tell
us everything that we need to know my
point is this so if you want the guy
don't wait until late june and sign him
to another contract at a one million
dollar base salary with an upside that
you only get if you're basically the
super bowl mvp and the regular season
mvp i mean that if he would have made
seven and a half million this year it
would have been the greatest deal dollar
for dollar in the history of sports
because it would have meant they would
have won a super bowl and and he would
have been the regular season mvp and he
would have played 90 of the time and
everything would have been great he's
getting 3.7 million most likely for this
season and when you consider the top of
the market now and new money is 45
million that's peanuts and if you want
that guy if you decide you want him
chris they need to find a way to take
care of him
sooner rather than later and not play a
game with him because i think that that
kind of comes through that long answer
that we played everything he's done he's
busted his ass for the team he's gone
without seeing his kids he gets up early
he gets out the door he gets to work
he's done everything they've asked right
and if there isn't a financial reward
that he doesn't have to fight and
scratch and claw for and engage in this
nuanced negotiation that takes way too
long that that's not the way it should
be if you value the people who have made
the contributions and kept you from
having a four and 12 season frankly you
got to take care of them if you believe
they're part of the future yeah i i
agree with you 100 there i do and you
know in the grand scheme of things
even taking care of them is probably
going to be basically peanuts for the
quarterback position i mean when it's
all said and done they're not gonna have
to pay them you know 20 something
million dollars that's not gonna happen
so you know either way they're gonna
come out with a good deal as far as a
starting quarterback and mike here's the
last thing because i know we gotta go
but like
okay good there's no rush matt casey
said all right the the other thing too
is
you know
to all the things you've said where
you've been spot on and we talk about it
hey if they want to bring them back they
better do it pretty soon they need to
mold the guy this off season they can't
wait till june they gotta get back in
the lab with a pen in the pad right like
you know dr dre said they gotta do that
they gotta get in there and start fixing
mechanics hey talk about the language of
play calling we talked about hey when i
call this play i'm thinking this and if
i don't have this then i want you to do
that all of those things got to be
worked out and that's only going to
happen if they make somewhat of a pretty
quick decision on him so they can get
back in the meeting room get back on the
field work on mechanics and play in the
game the patriot way
and there's nothing else they need to
convert the entire playbook to the
hieroglyphics that he uses on social
media please don't do that as
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports